recently the first season of The Last of
Us premiered on HBO The Action takes
place in a post-apocalyptic world to
catch the attention of those who haven't
played the computer game the creators
developed a PR campaign that used AR
technology in Snapchat there was a
filter that would make any building look
as it would in the post-apocalypse AR
technology in advertising is nothing new
for example a few years ago Ikea
presented an application which was able
to place virtual furniture from their
catalog in your apartment normal shops
long ago allowed you to try on new items
with the help of your phone and now
using your smartphone you can dive into
a post-apocalyptic world and feel as if
you are the last of us don't forget to
subscribe to our channel so you don't
miss our new videos